hey what's up everyone its rob and
welcome to my tutorial for the paper
popper stunt plane in my last video I
showed a new design for a paper popper
that you can change into a stunt plane
that you can get to come back to you and
a lot of people voted to see it while
based off my last paper popper the
larger air pocket makes it easier to pop
with just a simple Ted - the popper it
transformed into an awesome stunt plane
that you can get to do flips and come
back to you it with some adjustment and
practice oh you mean one piece of
printer paper you can use a white sheet
or a colored sheet whichever you prefer
I'm using an eight-and-a-half by 11
letter sized one and once you have that
let's get started to make the popper
make sure your paper is in the landscape
orientations with the longer edges
horizontal then you could take the top
edge fold it down to the bottom edge
line them up as neatly as you can and
then make a crease along the top of the
paper all the way across if you'd like
you can crease your finger now again
just to make sure that it's sharp but it
doesn't need to be too sharp then you
can open up the paper and you'll see we
made this line in the middle we're now
going to take the top edge of the paper
and fold it directly on to that middle
line lining it up as neatly as you can
and then creasing along the top once
again now you'll see we have this little
top section that we fold it down we're
just going to fold this section in half
once again by taking the top and folding
it down to the middle so just take it
round it off a little bit and fold it
directly on to that middle line once
again all the way across and give it a
nice crease so now we have this bar on
top of the paper right here we're just
going to fold it down in half directly
on this line or crease that we already
have so just take it and fold it down
one time and then you can flatten it out
once you flatten it out all we need to
do now is to turn it over and we're
going to take the edge here and fold it
across to the opposite edge so just take
it round it off a little bit in the
middle meet up the two edges here so you
need to just round it right here like
that meet the two edges together hold
them and then take your finger and just
pull in here a little bit to round that
off as best you can because it will be
very thick and then you can kind of
flatten it out like that holding these
two edges together then you can crease
it all the
lay down so if you like to set it down
on the table and just give it a crease
and that is it that's how you make the
paper popper now to load it all we need
to do is to grab it by this edge right
here so you'll see we have this little
bar or section we're going to pinch it
right here at this point where it meets
the rest of the paper and what we're
going to do is to just lift it up so if
you want to you could stick your finger
underneath it and lift it like that and
then pinch it and we're going to take
this edge of the paper and bring it down
and when you do that you'll see that
this corner here and this corner here go
below this edge so you're gonna pull it
down until those corners go directly
below this edge like this once they do
you're going to grab these two edges
together and pinch them so just take the
two edges and grab those corners and
pinch them together like that and that's
it you want to make sure that you're not
pinching this edge in between these
corners too tightly otherwise this part
cannot lift up which is what allows the
paper popper to pop by catching air in
this pocket so let's go ahead and give
it a try so you want to grab these two
corners on the bottom and this edge
right here this sliding edge should be
right around this corner or above right
there and then you're just going to
basically throw it like you're throwing
a ball just like that and as you'll see
the pocket open back up so when you do
reload it you need to open it fold it
back down one time and then you could
reload it once again just make sure
you're not grabbing this edge or
pinching it because if you're pinching
it in between here it will not ever pop
because it won't catch the air and it
won't lift up so just make sure it's
right there or above and then do it
there you go you can also change your
paper popper into a really cool stunt
glider that can do flips and come back
to you with some folds experimenting at
practice it's pretty simple and it looks
just like this and just know if you use
the paper popper a lot it's going to
probably start to rip a little bit and
if it does it probably won't make the
best plane because it's not going to be
aerodynamic like that so you might as
well just keep it as a paper
and just start making a new one from
scratch if you want to try to make the
plane it's going to fold these edges of
the popper down and then fold the
outside up just like that hold the
bottom here about an inch from the
bottom and just take one of these edges
here and bring it down on your thumb and
line up this edge with the bottom edge
here like that about an inch from the
bottom right there should be fine and
then crease it all the way across just
like that and then do the same on the
other side by just taking the edge
meeting it up and rounding it off a
little bit with this one and then you
can crease it and then do that all the
way across the top again so you should
have something that looks just like this
then only you need to do is to fold the
outside up about a centimeter or so so
if you want to use your pinky as a guide
just about that width maybe like right
there again it's pretty forgiving it's
not you know it's not going to matter
whether you fold it off a little bit or
if it's if it's shorter or longer just
experiment with it and give it a shot
and you could just try out different
types and see which one flies they're
all gonna fly different you're gonna
find that they're all going to probably
fly a little bit different some might
come back some might do flips but there
you go let's give it a shot and see how
it flies okay so here's the plane I just
finished from the popper and there's a
couple ways you can try to throw it you
can throw it straight out you can tilt
it up like this and toss it almost
straight up or you could hold it
sideways and also toss it upside down
and up so just try experiment with a
whole bunch of different ways of
throwing it and you'll see that it'll
actually it'll change depending on how
you throw it so I'm gonna try to throw
it like this tilting it to the left and
see what happens
so there you go pretty much kind of came
back to me a little bit there just like
that
[Music]
thanks for watching my tutorial for the
paper popper stunts glider I hope you
guys enjoyed it and if you did be sure
to give it a thumbs up or like down
below and don't forget to click that
subscribe and notification bell if
you're not already leave me a comment
down below let me know were you able to
do it did you have any trouble did you
like it better than the old one I think
it's a lot better because the pocket on
the old one is so much smaller I
understand why people were having some
difficulty getting it to pop whereas
this one the pockets a lot bigger and
you can actually open this a little more
and kind of pop it easier in my opinion
be sure to practice it and that you're
not holding the edge down just like I
said also practice your throws with the
glider and try different things
different angles different curves and
maybe just try different folds in it as
well me and Jeremy Shafer are working on
a new transforming ninja star that looks
just like this and transforms like that
let me know if you want to see it leave
a comment down below and also I'll put a
poll up in the corner here let me know
if you guys want to see that next I hope
you guys enjoyed your Thanksgiving in
holidays and I'll be sure to see you
soon til next time